buonasera
oggi vorrei iniziare questa
presentazione che racconta storie storie
di donne perché amnesty international è
convinta che fra le grandi sfide di
questo secolo che riguardano i diritti
umani ci siano propri diritti delle
donne può apparire strano che ancora si
deve apparire parlare di diritti delle
donne ma in un periodo come questo in
cui c'è una grossa crisi probabilmente
si deve invece ritornare da un lato a
riflettere su cosa questi diritti sono e
dall'altro ad affrontare ea vedere cosa
le donne stanno facendo nel mondo e oggi
io vi vorrei parlare delle donne che
stanno lottando in medio oriente e in
nord africa
vorrei iniziare con questa donna che in
realtà è una bambina la vedete qui
questa è una foto del 92 e voi lo rivela
mostro perché questa bambina
agli inizi degli anni 2000
e morta si e fatta saltare in aria come
kamikaze è uscita dal suo campo profughi
dove viveva a betlemme ed è andata in
israele e ho deciso di mettere questa
foto qui oggi perché ovviamente per
quello che sta succedendo a gaza in
questi giorni e per perché mi ha
suscitato una riflessione che cosa
sapevamo noi di questa donna di questa
bambina ho di lei quando si e fatta
saltare in aria e che cosa invece
sappiamo di queste donne che sono coloro
che hanno guidato negli ultimi due anni
sostanzialmente le rivoluzioni nei paesi
arabi queste sono donne che non solo
hanno partecipato alle rivolte in egitto
in tunisia che stanno lottando in siria
in bahrain ma le hanno proprio guidate
le foto di cui che vedete qui sono
quelle di una un'altra ragazza che si
chiama zainab è una delle leader della
lotta per i diritti umani in bahrain che
è un paese del golfo
lei non fa molto si siede
sostanzialmente nel traffico da sola ma
è diventata talmente pericolosa per il
suo governo che è stata arrestata e
processata ben 15 volte è stata
torturata
ma a differenza della bambina di prima
sappiamo molto di lei perchè è una
ragazza che grazie alla comunicazione ai
social media soprattutto grazie a
twitter essenzialmente ci fa conoscere
fa conoscere a chiunque voglia a
seguirla minuto per minuto
ora per ora tutto quello che succede nel
suo paese e quello a cui lei assiste
assistiamo anche in sua compagnia o di
chi la segue ai suoi processi e sa cosa
succede quando lei esce dal carcere
queste sono tutte donne come vedete
donne velate e non sono più da sole
rispetto a quanto accadeva
vent'anni fa e della grossa grandissima
differenza che ci permette di metterci
in relazione molto di in maniera molto
diversa con loro io in palestina ho
vissuto cinque anni e mi ricordo cosa
facevamo per sostenere le bambine
e le donne come quella che avete visto
prima noi sostanzialmente esportavamo
dei modelli e cercavamo di aiutarle a
sostenersi da sole ma quello che
effettivamente mancava e che adesso c'è
è una grande possibilità di messa in
rete di messa in condivisione e di un
concetto completamente nuovo di
partecipazione che rende possibile a chi
adesso è qui da questa parte chi sembra
essere anche molto lontano da loro in
realtà di far sentire loro la nostra
comprensione e la nostra partecipazione
molto vicino questa è una opportunità
enorme non solo per donne come queste ma
anche per noi perché ci permette di
mettere in comune esperienze che
potrebbero apparire fondamentalmente
molto lontane
il lavoro che amnesty international
vuole fare sta cominciando a fare con
queste donne proprio questo quello di
mettere in relazione è in forte
condivisione grazie anche alle
tecnologie
l'attivismo di persone che come noi si
trovano in paesi che non si trovano in
situazioni così gravi e che permette
però di aiutare molto bene e anche
facendo molta pressione sui governi di
questi paesi per aiutare le donne come
loro
la cosa più toccante anche quando si
parla con queste donne è di poter
sentire e toccare effettivamente con
mano quella che è la loro esperienza
qualche giorno fa si è venuta a trovare
un attivista siriana che è dovuta
scappare dalla siria con due bambini
molto piccoli perché era stata
ripetutamente arrestata e sottoposta a
torture a trattamenti veramente molto
degradanti bene lei grazie alla
connessione con le persone che ancora in
siria sono e grazie all'utilizzo dei
media sociali sostanzialmente del
digitale permette di alle compagnie che
ancora sono in siria di farle sentire
comunque vicine e di dar loro anche una
visione del mondo che non sia
esclusivamente chiusa su ciò che stanno
vivendo è uno dei grossi problemi di
paesi come la palestina
ad esempio che sono stati per decine di
anni chiusi esclusivamente sui loro sul
loro punto di vista il fatto di poter
mettere in connessione la loro vita con
la nostra da un grande senso di speranza
e di apertura e questo attivista siriana
ci ha raccontato che lei si è trovata a
riccione sulla spiaggia e ha fotografato
dei bambini che giocavano e ha mandato
via twitter queste foto alle sue amiche
attiviste in siria che stanno in quel
momento stavano sotto le bombe e le ha
rese estremamente felici e gli ha dato
una forza enorme questo vi dà la misura
di quanto poco vasti e quanto invece
tanto possano fare le tecnologie per
sostenere il nostro attivismo per
aiutare queste persone in particolare
queste donne in un processo storico
assolutamente fondamentale perché le
primavere arabe non sono finite sono in
corso anche se se ne parla un pochettino
meno ma non è stata una come dire una
stagione che si è conclusa è un
grandissimo processo che probabilmente
continuerà per molti molti anni ma di
cui le donne sono protagoniste perché
sono effettivamente loro il motore di
questo cambiamento
grazie